en el vídeo pasado aproximamos el área
por debajo de la gráfica de una función
utilizando cuatro rectángulos que tenían
el mismo largo y cuya altura estaba dada
por la función evaluada en el extremo
izquierdo de cada intervalo lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es
generalizar esta idea para una función
arbitraria en un intervalo arbitrario
con una cantidad arbitraria de
rectángulos bueno déjame pasar aquí
abajo para enseñarte a qué me refiero
entonces por aquí por aquí voy a dibujar
el eje que por acá voy a dibujar el eje
x así más o menos grandes para que
veamos qué sucede el eje x y lo que
queremos es estimar el área por debajo
de la gráfica de una función digamos ye
igual a efe de x en un intervalo dado en
el intervalo a coma b vale entonces
queremos queremos estimar la región que
queda entre esta pared y
esta pared por debajo de la gráfica de
la función y para hacer esto vamos a
utilizar n rectángulos n rectángulos
una vez más la altura de estos
rectángulos va a estar dada por la
función evaluada en el extremo izquierdo
entonces el primer rectángulo pues
quedaría aquí pegadito a y se vería algo
más o menos de este estilo su altura
sería f entonces esto de aquí es pelear
y el rectángulo digamos que se ve algo
de este estilo obama entonces aquí
tenemos el primer rectángulo y este
rectángulo empieza en nada y llega a un
cierto punto vamos a ponerle un nombre a
este punto vamos a ponerle x uno va
ahora como vamos a querer que todos los
puntos aquí abajo sean x con un
subíndice a le vamos a llamar x 0 esto
nada más es una convención para que
después todo quede un poco más bonito
vamos con el segundo rectángulo el
segundo yo creo que es un poquito más
chaparrito y osea ahora su altura sería
de f x 1 y llegaría más o menos como por
acá
entonces ahí tenemos el rectángulo
número 2 llegada al punto x 2 y de
manera similar el rectángulo número 3
tiene altura fx2 f x 2 y llega
llega al punto x 3 x 3 quien lo voy a
poner con el color rojo este x 3 está
entonces vamos a seguir haciendo eso
vamos a seguir poniendo más y más
rectángulos hasta que lleguemos a ver a
quien ven necesitamos el enésimo
rectángulo este rectángulo lo voy a
pintar con este color rosa para entonces
nos quedaría más o menos algo de de este
estilo llegaría hasta la función
evaluada en este extremo izquierdo o sea
hasta aquí
y sería el enésimo el enésimo rectángulo
cuál sería su punto inicial pues vamos a
ver cómo nos quedan las cosas el
rectángulo 1 empiezan en x 0 y termine
en x 1 el rectángulo 2 empieza en x 1 y
terminen x 2 o sea los rectángulos
siempre empiezan en x y el subíndice es
uno menos que el número del rectángulo
así que aquí nos quedaría x n -1 y para
que todo quede bonito a ver le voy a
llamar x en ba bueno ahí están los n
rectángulos vamos ahora a su largo vamos
a pensar que otra vez el largo de todos
estos es igual digo hay otras formas de
hacer la aproximación en los cuales
podemos pensar que el largo es diferente
pero ahorita vamos a pensar que todos
tienen el mismo largo de esta forma si
le llamamos delta x delta x al largo de
cada uno de los rectángulos pues delta x
se calcula midiendo toda la distancia
que sería venosa y dividiendo entre m
porque queríamos en largos iguales ok
observa ya teniendo delta x igual a esto
podemos poner que a es igual a x 0 que x
1 es igual a x 0
delta x que x2 es igual a x1 más delta x
simplemente de x1 avanzamos el largo y
así sucesivamente hasta b b que es x cn
pero que también lo podemos pensar como
x n
uno más de elda x muy bien con todo esto
ya tenemos la anotación y las
convenciones necesarias para calcular
nuestra aproximación como le haríamos
para calcular esta área esta área
aproximada aproximada
pues nada más hay que sumar el área del
rectángulo 1 lo voy a poner aquí que
este es el rectángulo 1 a eso tenemos
que sumar el área del rectángulo 2
este es el rectángulo 2 después el área
del rectángulo 3 el rectángulo 3 va a
poner así
y así sucesivamente hasta el último
rectángulo y hasta el área del
rectángulo del rectángulo en
rectángulo n cómo hacemos para calcular
el área de un rectángulo pues
simplemente hay que multiplicar su
altura por su base el primer rectángulo
su altura es f efe
pero en vez de ponerle a le voy a poner
x0 para que los demás me queden
parecidos
entonces ese f x 0 por el largo el largo
es delta x vamos al rectángulo 2 ahora
tiene altura f de x 1 verdad
efe de x 1 entonces aquí nos quedaría
efe x 1 por delta x con el rectángulo 3
pasa algo similar sería fx 2 está a su
altura por delta x por delta de x el
delta x es el mismo de siempre que es
venenosa entre n y así hasta que
llegamos al enésimo el enésimo su altura
sería fx n
1 y su largo es delta x muy bien con
esto terminamos esto nos da una
aproximación nos da una aproximación
para el área por debajo de la gráfica de
la función igual a fx
sin embargo sin embargo para
acostumbrarnos a la anotación que se
utiliza usualmente vamos a cambiar esto
a la notación sigma la notación sigma se
usa mucho en las aproximaciones de
rectángulos pero en general cuando uno
quiere hacer suma entonces lo que
tenemos que poner es esta letra sigma es
una sigma la griega y vamos a sumar
desde igual a 1 hasta en la expresión
efe de x y menos 1 x delta x esta
expresión de aquí esta anotación
matemática ya abrevia todo esto de aquí
arriba y nos indica la aproximación para
el área que queremos y cómo le hacemos
para leer esta anotación pues dice lo
siguiente vamos a tener varios humanos y
cada sumando está dado de la forma f x y
menos 1 por delta x entonces él y
decimos sumando lo que hace es calcular
calcular el área del décimo rectángulo
chips
aún así para el décimo sumando para el
décimo sumando tenemos fx y menos 1 la
altura por delta x el largo entonces
tenemos el área del décimo rectángulo y
estos símbolos indican que hay que sumar
desde el primer rectángulo hasta el
enésimo rectángulo muy bien en realidad
no estamos haciendo nada muy diferente a
lo que hicimos acá arriba verdad acá
teníamos una función concreta cuatro
rectángulos que iba de 1 a 3 y acá abajo
acá abajo lo estamos generalizando para
una cantidad arbitraria de rectángulos
una función arbitraria en un intervalo
arbitrario y además lo estamos poniendo
en una anotación un poco más matemática